if the treasury bond futures denominated
in bitcoin and nasdaq denominated in
bitcoin uh news flash they're going down
uh what what is this is this just the
the continuation of the trend
yeah i mean i just like to it's just a
fun thought experiment to denominate
assets in each other you know we can
look at usd but i think really if you
look at you know kind of relative
performance of these asset classes it's
quite clear if i didn't label the chart
and just showed you bullish or bearish
on this asset what would you say you'd
say bearish right denominating anything
in bitcoin really over a long-term time
frame uh the chart looks terrible and
there's a reason for that it's because
bitcoins are performing everything um so
treasury bonds are trending to zero in
bitcoin big tech is trying to zero and
sound money and really
most everything else um and what we can
say is you know we've preached this and
we preached this you know while
bitcoin's down 50 60
if you denominate your standard of
living in this the soundest money over
the long term you you'll do great um and
so it's tough to hold through volatility
it's tough to see your purchases down 40
50 30 whatever it is
but long term if your unit of account is
is superior to others
you'll relatively outperform and i think
that's what we're seeing today and
that's going to be the trend for the
next decade plus
joe john what questions you guys got
dylan i just want to ask you about how
you think uh about cycles in general
obviously bitcoin has acted slightly
different this cycle than the previous
ones do you think that this is kind of
what we're going to see going forward
and just how do you think about cycles
in general
yeah um i've kind of had a little bit of
a thesis that the you know three year 80
percent drawdowns and bull bear cycles
are somewhat concluded and that
bitcoin's matured enough to where it's
still very volatile and because of these
derivatives and legacy system volatility
right much of bitcoin's recent drawdown
from say november was because of legacy
risk off um and that beat and that usd
denominator in btc but
i think for for the time or like you
know for the future what we're going to
see is
shorter term kind of um maybe parabolic
runs and then 50 drawdowns i think
really that kind of prolonged cycle
where bitcoin was under the surface and
didn't really get much much attention
around the world other than just kind of
being cyberpunk niche internet money i
think those days are slowly coming to an
end even though we still are definitely
in a big echo chamber on twitter and
just you know being kind of the
bitcoiners in general but more and more
increasingly i think it's it's relevance
at a nation state level on a
geopolitical level is stronger than ever
and for that reason i think you know the
days of bitcoin dying for years on end
and you know just everyone forgetting
about it uh relatively is somewhat over
john what do you got dylan my question
is just around like is this a make or
break moment for bitcoin we see
terabyting a bunch of bitcoin we see
everything around the world basically
acting as a perfect storm is this year
gonna be a make or break for bitcoin
yeah i mean it's a make definitely
definitely a break and i don't know if
it uh i don't know if you know bitcoin
goes and appreciates by an order of
magnitude this year i'm certainly
extremely bullish and uh palm funny
enough wait i was getting i was getting
some heat yesterday saying weren't you
bearish and i was like i've gone go
every single day and every single week
and said i own more bitcoin than ever
how the heck can you think i'm bearish
yeah like cautiously optimistic about
the global economy because it doesn't
look great um
but i think in terms of making break
you're seeing things like exxon right
they're saying hey we're actually
reducing methane
through bitcoin mining all these things
that were kind of like niche narrative
talking points are actually coming to
fruition um you know legal tender
happened last year i think we're gonna
get some fun announcements uh in about
two weeks in miami at the conference
you're gonna see other kind of huge
developments like russia saying and not
that we're a supporter of russia but
they can use an apolitical neutral
currency if they wish
for global trade things like this uh
were really kind of speeding up the
event horizon faster than i think a lot
of people thought and for that reason
you know exponential technology
exponential adoption
i wouldn't be surprised to see bitcoin
continue to rip and some of these macro
catalysts that we're talking about can
definitely exponent even further hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time